top three oh my gosh
yes wow we made it to the
end congrats to all three of you
scarlett bobo
rita bagga and priyanka i am so happy to
talk to you here on et canada pride
all three of you did such an amazing
job on season one of canada's drag race
thank you it was the worst out of the
three because we're trying to figure out
who's gonna win this thing so
listen i'll tell you this if we are
talking track records
bobo you are in the lead
that said all three of you were so damn
good it is going to be such a close call
i just want to say off the top you know
how important
it is for canada to have a show like
this with queer talent
and representation and it has just been
so amazing to see it on air
congratulations to being a part of that
and sharing all of your own personal
stories
thank you for that yeah well thank you
thank you for single-handedly taking
rita and i down
out of the gate rita bagga you won the
first main challenge
rita bega congratulations
um you are the winner of this week's
challenge
[Applause]
did that you think give you an extra
oomph in your step would you say uh well
it
gave me confidence winning the first
week
and we don't want to be uh you know the
girl
that left the first week so it just
gave me that motivation to continue and
to
keep going and to keep winning
so it was a roller coaster and there was
no shade to the first girl who was sent
home
uh she i would just like to see her in
season two because i
love me love some juice box priyanka you
and i have a bit of
history together are you my ex-boyfriend
i mean i wasn't going to reveal that
but no we didn't date but my
ex-boyfriend looks exactly like him so
i'm triggered
oh no sorry you are very
inspiring to me because you left behind
a
children's television gig which you know
people
dream of that but you left it to follow
your
dream and look where you are now hi
canada did you get my name not a copycat
fish did you get my name it's
me and my girl serving you spectacles
other girls
forgettable there's something about like
being an artist
and wanting to find something where you
can express your art and creativity
and and kidstv has so many rules and i
think that
parents forget that kids are smarter
than they think
my presence as a gay
person of color posting kids tv
was the political statement in itself
it's so full circle and
i'm so proud and and it's okay to take
risks as long as you know you're meant
to do it
and i truly truly believe that i meant
to be a drag
entertainer scarlett bobo i must say
that every single week i knew
that i was going to get something
just mind-blowing on the runway with
that said you had an interesting run
because
up until last week you had never won a
main challenge
congratulations you are the winner of
this week's maxi challenge
yes you won the ball
i won do you think that kind of slow
burn
we'll say was beneficial to you they
gave you the underdog storyline for sure
i do think it helped because a lot of
the fans were like
what the hell and so many fans are
getting really angry and i was like you
know what
it's it's kind of good to have these
fans like in my corner
rooting for me so i think it i think the
slow burn definitely helped
um and you know what it did really make
that final
win just that much sweeter rita
i know there was a bit of drama this
season
surrounding rita i talked to jimbo last
week jimbo's still
salty about the denim challenge i sucked
this interview and jimbo said that he
was mad because i was not wearing denim
that was a hundred percent denim so
don't get bitter just get better thank
you
for the eliminated queens are returning
on tomorrow's episode
i'm guessing there's no there's no drama
at all without return right
we all hold hands and sing kumbaya
rita and priyanka can i say that you two
are the official
lip sync assassins of the season is that
right
the proper time because you haven't seen
me yet girl well that is true
but priyanka i feel like with you
priyanka
um you showing lip sync skills in the
bottom two
gave you some of your best moments on
the show
watched i drove all night at least three
times a day
and i still cannot believe that that's
me
i'm like you better go off girl
you better fight to be here i want you
to each
tell me starting with priyanka i'll go
with you first what your own personal
favorite runway look of your own was on
the show
my personal favorite runway look ever
was my hair look orange and blue
and also that episode as a whole for me
was really great i got to talk about my
dad
i got to show the world that it's okay
to still be in the closet but
i'm here to help you come out of it and
that look is what represented that
i think my personal favorite had to be
the pageant runway
um because you know i don't serve
glamour too often but when i do honey
i'm gonna make it look fierce and edgy
and i'm gonna make it look
bobo and i i remember i just wanted to
come around that corner and i wanted to
make brooklyn gasps when i stared right
in her eyes and then she was like
i was like okay i've succeeded what
about you rita what's your favorite look
of your own
um i would say it was the plastic
challenge
so good yeah and i was so proud to uh
you know not only to win this this
challenge but to just
create the whole thing and also also i
feel like i won
two challenges which was to create this
and the other one was to manage bobo's
strength that day
[Music]
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive
interviews click subscribe or watch
these videos